yeah so so thanks for your great
questions uh you know it's
usually i get a lot of uh you know
shallow questions that i've answered a
million times already but you're
really uh really well done i looked at
your list with questions and i thought
that's going to be a tough one
all right i'm here with the
scintillating
sabine sabine haasenfelder and we're
going to talk about physics
a bit of consciousness a bit of
something called emergence
so sabine why don't you tell us tell the
audience a bit about yourself
as well as what you're working toward
uh i'm a theoretical physicist and i
presently work at the frankfurt
institute for advanced studies
in germany and you know my day-to-day
research is mostly
dark matter super fluid dark matter in
particular
but i also do some stuff in the
foundations of quantum mechanics and you
know i'm generally broadly interested in
the foundations of physics
super fluid dark matter dark matter is
it's dark and it's not
clear what it is and you're qualifying
it by saying superfluid dark matter
why is that well um
so this is a particular type of dark
matter that
um was proposed by
a group around justin curry about five
years ago
and the curious thing about it is that
this kind of super fluid
um appears like modified gravity
and i don't know if you've been
following this whole debate but there's
there's this big fight
in astrophysics about whether it's dark
matter
so it's stuff made of particles or
whether we have gotten something wrong
with gravity and we need to modify
einstein's theory of general relativity
and
um so that there are benefits to either
side i would say
and and people can't decide what's the
right thing and
um the amazing thing about this type of
superfluid dark matter is that it
combines the benefits of both
without the disadvantages of either so
when i
when i first read about this i was like
that's the thing to do
and um i feel super super lucky that i
actually got a research grant that
allows me to further study um this type
of dark matter how does it combine the
benefits of modifying the field
equations of einstein
well it doesn't exactly modify the field
equations but what this
superfluid dark matter does is that
there is an additional
force in the fluid which is mediated by
the phonons
after condensation and um it
this force appears like it sits on top
of gravity
so it makes gravity stronger which is
exactly
um what we observe and now the
interesting thing about it is that
since it's generated by this
condensation
process it's a very regular force that
has
a lot more patterns to it than you would
get by normal dark matter that you can
distribute
however which way you like so this
normal dark matter
has a big problem reproducing certain
patterns that we observe
like the baryonic tolerant fischer
relation just to mention an example
and superfluid dark matter can reproduce
these patterns quite easily
so that what you're working toward
primarily right now
is just fleshing that theory out making
it
match with predictions unless it already
does i mean
making a match with current data yeah
basically so i'm
you know on the on the one side there's
this question like how do you connect us
with the data but they're
also on the theoretical side they are
just things that are
have not been very well explored um so
you know i'm a theoretical physicist i
work more on
understanding the theory part and um
you know but i i have a student and a
collaborator um who are more on the
observational side
so of course we're hoping to connect the
two
and what's your youtube channel what's
the goal
what's the goal yeah for everyone
watching this you should check out
i'll include a link to your youtube
channel in the description
check out her channel because if you're
someone who's interested in physics and
if you're an undergrad in physics
even if you're a graduate of physics
you'll have plenty to learn from her
channel
she has music videos as well as far as i
know sabine you've moved your music
videos to another channel though some of
the old ones remain
and yeah so what the heck is why are you
doing the youtube channel
maybe it's self-explanatory but i want
to hear it from you and then
second what's the deal with the music
videos
well so um i've been in science
communication like
for almost 15 years now and i used to
mostly do
writing as you probably know i've
written this blog called back reaction
for quite a long time
and i've just found in the long run that
writing doesn't appeal to a pretty big
group of people
and there's generally an issue with um
blogging which is that the audience is
pretty much self-selecting
so after you've written on a particular
topic for some time which in
my case is mostly particle physics
you're you're pretty much stuck
with a certain group of people so you
live in this bubble
and then if you get interested in
something else like it's been the case
with we
um you you totally talk past your
audience so no one gives a [ __ ]
basically um i see and um
in so you developed too narrow of an
audience over time
with blogs yeah right and and now the
thing is that
um search engine um optimization has
been going
um in a way that doesn't really help
this so people don't just
go online and search for
something on a blog that just doesn't
exist and now the interesting thing
about youtube is that
they will try to find an audience for
your content
that's what the search algorithm does
and now you know there's a long
conversation to be
uh have had about how well this actually
works but
in principle the idea is good you know
they take your content and they
they try to find people who may be
interested in it and i think this has
really helped me
um to get the stuff that i've more
recently been interested in which leads
more towards philosophy foundations of
quantum mechanics and more generally the
um sometimes not very well working
connection between science and science
policy
um so so this is all stuff um that
i found gets a quote across much better
on youtube and i mean then there are
obvious things like that it's easier to
um explain some things if you can use
graphics
right right and when you say that you're
interested in the philosophy of the
foundations of quantum mechanics are you
referring to
the different interpretations of quantum
mechanics
well um i'm you know i said i'm a
theorist but
uh i'm actually more strictly speaking
i'm a phenomenologist
it's just that i try to avoid the word
because a lot of people don't know what
it means
yeah so actually a quick aside
phenomenology
for the majority of our audience they
might be familiar with the philosophy
that comes from hussero exactly and
phenomenology particle phenomenology
sounds like oh
are you talking about the umvelt of a
quark i don't know if you are
aware of the philosophical phenomenology
but if you if you are can you delineate
it between the particle phenomenology
yes so the phenomenology um in particle
physics has nothing to do with the
philosophical area of phenomenology but
it's
um it basically sits in the middle
between theory and experiment so you're
trying to develop
a model that you can connect to what is
actually measurable
so the the theoretical side in
particular in particle physics tends to
be
pretty much only math right that that
that's what you do
and then on the experimental side you
measure and the phenomenology
um is that group of people where we are
making a connection between the two
so it would be as if newton came up with
the theory of gravity
and then someone said well here's how we
can test the theory of gravity that's
the phenomenologist and then the
experimentalists go out and do the
actual testing is that the divide
um yeah roughly speaking except that
normally it's the case that you have a
theory which is much much more
complicated than newtonian gravity so
you have to coax
something out of it that you can
actually go and measure i see i see
and i'm sure you've heard of some of
these new theories of everything that
have been developed recently two major
ones
and for example weinsteins and wolframs
and i'm i want to know if you're
familiar with it and if you see as a
phenomenologist
any clear way of getting a prediction
from them
uh no i don't see such a
way i'm sure that they both have been
thinking about
it uh but it's a you know this is a
really
complicated process
um i'm not even
sorry i'm not even one to say that a
prediction is necessary
in the short term when you're exploring
i know that i
in your book lost in math it's it's like
hey there's been 20 years with string
theory
maybe more and it's it seems like
right right well these two new theories
don't have that
long of a history so it's not such a
detriment at least in my
estimation that they don't have
prediction predictions associated with
it even a fineman said that
feynman had this great talk i don't know
if you saw it but he was saying don't
prematurely throw out a new physics
theory just because it doesn't comport
with the data and doesn't make
experiments
and he gave a great analogy imagine the
mayans 500 600 years ago
and they had wonderful predictions
it was based on a wrong model but it all
fit with the data of how the sun of when
the sun is going to come out
and then someone says hey i think that
the sun actually revolves that the earth
revolves around the sun
and and then they say well can you
predict when the moon is going to have
an eclipse and that person i know i
haven't
i haven't gotten it that far and i'm
like ah forget your theory then
yeah certainly i mean um it can take a
long time to
understand a theory on a depth
so that you can reliably make a
prediction
so and and that certainly that's
certainly a problem that
we see in the foundations with a lot of
people who
are working alone or in very small
groups
uh it can take like a really long time
to get anywhere
and uh as long as they don't have
as long as they have nothing to show for
everyone else is like
yeah no i don't want to even think about
it right
so it's kind of it's a process where the
rich get richer
and the poorer never get anywhere have
you read lee smolin's book on
the trouble with physics yes i read that
it seems like there's plenty of
parallels between lost and math and
and the trouble with physics do you see
any disagreements with
your point of view and lisa mullins in
the theory of
sorry in the trouble with physics
well there are some parallels of course
in that
i think we're both concerned about
where the foundations of physics are
headed
and that there are there's too much
emphasis
on some few research directions
um my book is more broadly about the
foundations of physics
why lee's book is more specifically
about string theory
what's the difference you ask i think
i'm far less critical of string theory
um than the years
um but i'm somewhat more critical of low
quantum gravity
than he is right so you know um
there are differences so how do you
define a theory
of everything is it simply unifying
gravity with the other three forces or
or is there something more
well you want to unify it so that that
it's consistent
you know if you just take the standard
model and you lump gravity on top of it
that's kind of a theory which describes
both particle physics as
we use it today and general relativity
but it's internally inconsistent
so what people mean with the theory of
everything is a theory that combines all
these four forces
but is mathematically consistent and it
is widely believed that
this will require quantizing gravity so
quantum gravity is kind of part
um of the picture should a theory of
everything
have as one of its ingredients an
explanation for dark matter
or dark energy or is that unnecessary
it's just purely about
grand unified theory unifying these well
you definitely need to do something
about dark matter um
because you need some resolution to that
um i mean
look dark matter makes up like 85
percent of the matter in the universe
um so if your theory of everything does
not describe
most of what's in the universe that's a
pretty poor theory of everything i'd say
it's a theory of a few of a minority
yeah basically so when it comes to
dark energy um there really isn't
anything to explain you know you you can
just
fit all the observations that we have uh
quite well by just saying well it's a
cosmological constant and that's just a
constant of nature and here we have
measured it
and that's the value so there's uh
there's nothing wrong with that
so in the theory of everything in your
eyes the
there are some constants that simply
need to be measured
they can be taken for granted they don't
need to be explained
by some other fundamental process
they don't need to be explained no but
you know it would certainly be nice
if we were able to reduce the number of
um
constants that that we have right now so
this is certainly something that a lot
of people hope for
but strictly speaking it's not necessary
you know do you think it's in principle
possible
to r to actually reduce all the physical
constants to something else that's
emergence of just one
um well it it kind of depends on how you
would define that because
um i mean so i
depends on what you mean by constants
the thing is that
we have in our physical theories uh we
don't just have
numbers like numbers without units but
we also have dimensionful constants
and you need these to come from
somewhere
like i mean i'm talking about things
like uh the speed of light planck's
constant
um you know boltzmann's constant that
kind of stuff
and and i don't really see how um you
can get around actually measuring them
like how can we possibly derive them
yes um which is also something that
i think most people don't have in mind
when they're talking about the theory of
everything
you know this i mean theoretical
physicists like to just set all these
constants equal to one
all right so just to ease the
calculation
um so these are not the constants that
they normally talk about um when they
say we want to derive this but
usually what they talk about are
constants that do not have any units
so this may be for example the ratio
between the masses of
uh i don't know the higgs boson at the
electron or something like this so so
this would be a typical
example for a number that you would hope
you can actually derive
from your theory of everything and then
that theory may well maybe only require
one constant
i don't see why this would be impossible
but no one has managed to actually do
that
is there some current theory of
everything that you feel like is
on the right track is there one that in
your mind is the best candidate
well i mean there there are
so um so we didn't settle before i
answered the question uh if by theory of
everything
you want to include a grand unification
so the grand unification is a
certain kind of symmetry for the
the other three known forces besides
gravity
the forces in the standard model like
there's electromagnetism and the strong
and the weak nuclear force
so um what
physicists usually call a grant unified
theory is one that
combines these three forces and you
could say well they
are already in the standard model so
what's wrong with that and the answer is
well nothing really
but um you know it would be nicer if we
could
combine them to only one force which in
a certain limit gives rise to these
three forces and so normally when people
talk about the theory of everything
they um include grant unification in
that
so the theory of everything is this
combination of quantum gravity with
um the gut the
grand unified uh theory and um
so there are very few
theories um that do that um
for example and we were talking about uh
look quantum gravity a loop quantum
gravity doesn't really say anything
about the particle sector
so it does not it does not have a grand
unification
so i think and this is always a matter
of definition of course but i think
a lot of physicists would not call it a
theory of everything they would just say
it's a theory of quantum gravity
um and so string theory uh is a theory
of everything
um that um because
both gravity and all these forces come
out of the same thing so it's all
strings basically so
that's the idea um and then um there are
some other
um approaches where um people say that's
what they do but it's
you know it's difficult as i said
because um these tend to be pursued by
very few people so
they never seem to really be getting
anywhere and i have some of these
examples in my book like garrett lisey
for example with his
uh e8 um theory in principle that's
something that could be a theory of
everything but it
it you know he's pretty much working
alone and and so
it's it's a very long tedious process
and then
you know there are things like causal
fermion models and you might may put on
this list
eric weinstein and um you know maybe
maybe
from um things like that and the word
from actually
what my understanding is he doesn't say
anything about the unification of of the
interaction
um on the other hand he claims he has to
say something about the foundations of
quantum mechanics
so you know you get into the details uh
very very quickly
um there's also um asymptotically safe
gravity which a lot of people
seem to be missing and i would say
that's a proper theory of everything
because you can very well combined that
with uh grant unification and people
have studied that kind of thing and it
basically removes
the discrepancy between the standard
model and the classical theory
of gravity so um you know
i i don't have very strong opinions
about which one of those
is the best as i said i'm i'm a
phenomenologist you know for for me
that's just
uh there are different approaches and
the question is how can you test them
so so that that's the question that i'm
most interested in
i see i see do you mind outlining for
our audience your views on strong
emergence you had a great paper
and from my understanding of it it was
first defining what strong emergence is
and then refuting it but then
at the end you save it and i i could be
incorrect
in my reading of it but yeah i kind of
so i i think that the the definition of
strong emergence that
uh i'm using there so so there's strong
weak emergence and i'm just using the
the common definition um so if um
you have a system um which is made of
small entities so it's uh composed of
some smaller stuff roughly speaking um
then
you can observe some behavior on
macroscopic scales
which you would say is emergent from
the behavior of the underlying
macroscopic
things and this
is a weak emergence if you can actually
derive
from the interactions and the properties
of these microscopic constituents what
is happening
happening on the macroscopic level so
you know a typical example would be that
you can derive
say the properties of molecules uh if
you know
if you have a theory of atoms because
the
the properties of the molecules actually
follow from
what the atoms do and you know the
electro orbitals and all that kind of
stuff
and what you're describing is so far it
sounds synonymous with
reductionism um well it's kind of well
reductionism goes the other way around
right so so weak emergence is kind of so
reductionism you dig
into the smaller scales weak emergence
you derive the microscopic scales
and and so weak emergence is compatible
with this reductionist picture and a
strong
emergence says that no you can have
entirely new phenomena on larger scales
that you cannot
derive from the properties of the
constituents of the system
so there's something really new coming
into into play there
and this um reductionism um hierarchy
basically breaks down somewhere
and now um as a particle physicist
who um has dealt with reductionism all
the time
of course it's a question that i'm very
interested in like
can you actually make strong emergence
work
because um if you know
that stuff is made of particles and we
have the laws
for these particles then in principle
everything derives from that
so that brings up the question like is
there some place where this derivation
can go wrong um
that's actually that's really really
hard to make sense of
theoretically and people have tried for
some time
um there there is a very interesting
paper by
um michael newton and
someone else i've forgotten the name of
the co-author
which is called um more really is
different you know that's an echo of
anderson's paper
uh more is different and so they try to
show
um that there are certain systems um
so so they use a very simplified system
with with uh
it's kind of like a um a board with
spins
um where you can define certain
quantities
in the example that they use is the
overall magnetization
um but you cannot derive them from the
properties
of the underlying system so this this
would be an example where you could
really speak of strong emergence
but you know the fine print on this
example which they use is
that it only becomes impossible to
actually
calculate this if you have a system that
is really infinitely large
so it's this infinity um that brings up
this impossibility
and of course nothing in nature is
really ever infinite
um so it's not a particularly good
example and there are some other
examples that that people have played
with and so um with my background in
particle physics
i was trying to look more directly at
the theories that we're actually using
and particle physics
so in the standard model just to be
concrete
that's a quantum field theory and in
quantum field theory we have
um a well-defined process of deriving
a theory on larger scales
from the theory on shorter scales
that's called effective field theory and
it's just a mathematical thing
um it's fairly new in a sense that i
mean it's been around for half a century
but it
it has really only entered uh i would
say you know
the consciousness of the community in
the in the past 20 years uh or something
like this
it's just technically there have been
some things that were not very well
understood in the early days but
uh today is kind of something that
everyone uh pretty much uses so you have
these equations that you can
just use to derive
in principle what happens on the
macroscopic scales from the underlying
physics now in many cases of course you
can't actually solve the equations
but they are but they are there so if
you think that
strong emergence is a real thing these
equations have to break down
at some point you know something has to
go wrong and
um the only way that um you can actually
have really new laws
on um large scales
is if something goes wrong in this
derivation and so in in this paper
i was making this argument you know
first i was explaining um
why we don't actually have something
like strong emergence
why all these examples that people have
come up with
are not realistic because they all draw
on um
something being infinitely large in one
way or the other
and then to say but look if you if you
look at effective field theory there is
a way in which this duration can go
wrong
and loosely speaking it's because there
are certain functions
that connect the theory on short
distances with the theory on
long distances that can run into
a singular point and let me be clear
that
just because the point is singular does
not mean that it's actually infinitely
large
but it it can be a point where the
function is actually
zero and all the derivatives are also
zero the thing is that if you're trying
to
predict how this function is going to
continue
from the short distances to the long
distances you can't
so and this is exactly what you would
need for strong emergence to be a real
thing
uh because in that case you would not be
able to derive
anything past that point
and i think that's a theoretical
possibility and that's what i
uh what i wrote this paper about which
is called a case for strong immersions
um this was one of the fqxi essay
contests
uh by the way if someone wants to look
that up um
but um i i don't know
any physical system that would actually
have this property
so it's theoretically i think it's
possible
uh but i i i don't have any reason to
think that it is actually
realized in nature have you heard of lee
smallin's principle of precedence
uh probably is that the thing that kind
of sounds like
leibniz principle of what's it called
something with reason
i believe it's that
somewhere in the universe let's say
electrons have conglomerated to form
some property by chance
well then other in other parts of the
universe the electrons know about this
rupert sheldrick if you were to be more
mystical he would call this morphic
resonate
morphic resonance i'm actually speaking
with him in a few hours i'm gonna
probe him on this but if this is true
this to me sounds like a case for strong
emergence as well
am i incorrect so
first i confuse these principles you
know lee likes to introduce
definitions and principles and they're
they're easy to
mix up and i think you're talking about
what he calls like the ensemble
interpretation
okay i could be wrong with my
terminology um
so he wrote a book about this recently
is this uh what you're referring to yeah
um i never thought about whether this
would be
whether this would be a case of a strong
emergence
um so i i sorry i just okay that's fine
that's fine what does this what does
strong emergence have to say about free
will
well um so as long as you only have
weak emergence um free will
does not exist uh for the simple reason
that
um we know that the underlying laws
in particular physics they are all
deterministic
you know you you give me an initial
state of the universe at some time i
apply my equations to it
and i can calculate the state of the
universe at any later time
it's it's kind of the same thing with as
with laplace's demon
the one difference is that we know of
quantum mechanics
so in addition to this deterministic
time evolution
there's an element of randomness
sprinkled over this which comes from the
measurement in quantum mechanics
so you have a combination of this
deterministic time evolution and then
every once in a while there's something
which
is unpredictable and neither
of which uh is anything like what we
normally kind of intuitively uh refer to
as free will and now i know of course
that there are a lot of
philosophers who have you know bend over
backwards
to try and find a definition for free
will that would be compatible with that
um you know this is this whole idea of
compatibilism and i don't really like to
argue about
you know the use of words but i you know
i would think that this notion of free
will that the philosophers are
discussing it's not a notion of free
will that
uh you know someone on the street uh
would
remotely understand you know you're
referring to the philosophers who say
that free will can be saved under
compatibilism
but their definition of free will
doesn't comport with people's intuitive
definition of free will
and the intuitive definition of free
will is called libertarianism
libertarian free will but it doesn't
matter
so yeah i'm not i i don't know so in
your opinion
do you believe that so i i think like
intuitively the idea that people have
is that there are like they're different
futures and you're using this thing you
call free will
which is basically you and you pick one
of these futures
and you know what i just said about
the underlying fundamental laws is that
it's a combination of determinism and
randomness
it doesn't leave place for anything like
that
and now the thing is that um if you
um have this breakdown of the connection
between the underlying law
and um the the law on larger states like
human beings
you and i stuff like that or maybe
already at the level of
viruses of god knows what um then in
principle you can have
entirely different laws and of course
that would bring up the question well
what are these laws but
well nobody knows but at least in
principle um
you know if you have strong emergence
there's room for that
do you believe in free will personally
no do you believe in god
no okay
let's move on then why why not agnostic
so that sounds like atheism yeah
i was about to say that it kind of
depends on whether you're asking me
in my profession as a scientist i would
say i'm agnostic
i don't care one way or the other if you
ask me personally you know the way that
i arrange my life
the way that i think about things i just
don't believe it
there's one way of getting around
belle's inequality and it's called super
determinism
and i'm i'm curious if you heard of it
and if you don't mind
explaining it to our audience and then
giving what your thoughts are
on it yes i've heard of it
um as i said in the very beginning i'm
partly working in the foundations
of quantum mechanics and and that's what
i'm working on
um so as you correctly say
super determinism is one of the ways to
get around the conclusions of bell's
theorem
which could be summarized as
if you have um a
local and deterministic theory like
roughly speaking you know very roughly
like the way that we are used to from
newtonian mechanics
you know um there's no randomness in
that it's all
deterministic there's no spooky action
at the
that kind of stuff in which
the outcomes of quantum mechanics are
actually determined but you cannot
predict them just
predict them just because you're missing
information
um so in this case the
quantum mechanics would be probabilistic
for the exact same reason
that you normally have probabilistic
predictions if you're throwing dice or
something this you just don't you're
you're missing information and so
belle's theorem tells you
um you can't do that
because any theory that has these
properties
will be in conflict with certain
experiments that have been done
so that's the thing that's called bells
inequality
and all theories of the type that i was
just talking about
um tell you have to obey this inequality
but experimentally you know that it can
be violated
so this this just rules out um this type
of
theory and a lot of people take this uh
to mean
that um you know quantum mechanics is
a non-local and it's a non-realist
theory and so on now um there is one
assumption of
inbound theorem which is called
statistical independence
and this is really really essential to
arrive at this conclusion
so if you throw out this assumption of
statistical independence you can very
well have a theory
that is deterministic and local and
still
violates um belt's inequalities and is
therefore compatible
with all observations and personally i
think that this is
much more reasonable to than to buy into
all this
you know philosophically uh
stuff about having a non-realist
interpretation that is somehow
you know always drawing on microscopic
concepts like detector measurements or
agents and the knowledge and that kind
of stuff and yet
still somehow compatible with
reductionism
the only thing that this requires is
that you give up on this
rather mathematical assumption of
statistical independence
now you may ask but what does it mean to
give up on
statistical independence so just
technically it means
that the outcome of the measurement
depends on the setting of the detector
and if you want to interpret this more
broadly it basically means that there
are
no places in the universe that are
entirely
disconnected from each other so
basically everything
is connected with everything else in in
very very subtle ways
so that you don't normally notice it
like
uh in in you know everyday life
we don't notice quantum effects and so
we also don't notice
these subtle correlations but if you do
a bell-type
test or some other quantum experiment uh
then um you become sensitive to that
how's this congruent with special
relativity that is that you can't break
the speed of light how is it that
we can be connected to what is
outside the the cone
well you you can have in special
relativity you can very well have
um correlations between um
you know distant points um they they
will be within some light cone of
something
um it just you know just because they're
in
in distant places does not mean they
were
created at a distance you know they can
have been
created locally right right do you have
any
thoughts on the emergence of possible
emergence of consciousness or whether or
not consciousness is fundamental
well um i don't think there's that
consciousness is all that
mysterious um so you know i'm a particle
for this is i'm a reductionist of course
i think that consciousness is weakly
emergent
as i guess most people in my discipline
you know it's it's it comes from
the way that complex systems
process information i would say and at
some level
it becomes beneficial for the system in
terms of natural selection to have a
self-monitoring process
so that's a peculiar thing about
consciousness is that most of the time
we're actually
not really aware of a lot of stuff
that's going on
so that that's all the stuff that we put
into the subconsciousness
um which basically frees up i guess some
processing power
uh on the higher levels and
um i i don't think that consciousness is
specific to
um you know biological forms of life
um but that sooner or later there will
be some computers that will reach some
levels of consciousness
so that is the sun even has a level of
consciousness
and the planets do
well you know there's there's
some it depends on exactly how you
define
it right so um if you define
consciousness um by information
processing
uh capacity uh together with some
level of self-awareness um then
you may find that pretty much any system
has a very very small level of uh
consciousness at some point uh but it's
rather
meaningless you know it's i guess that
you would have to pretty arbitrarily at
some point just say okay we call it
consciousness
if it's larger then i don't know
something right
now how do we test that i i can see that
we can come up with a measurement for
consciousness but it's not as if we can
it sounds like we're simply defining
consciousness as being
a certain level of self monitoring
information processing but it's not well
you know on this verbal level
of course you can't test it you actually
need to write down
a particular model that you know
quantifies
just what it takes um what's what
exactly needs to be happening in the
brain
um and and so on and so forth and uh
then i think you can very well go and
measure it
okay well what i'm saying is that if you
measure it
let's imagine there's someone who has
a low level of what we would predict to
be consciousness so let's just give it a
number
they have consciousness we would predict
that they have we can
we can figure out their brain state
almost exactly and we can
imagine that from our data from our
theory that they should have
consciousness at level 10. but they say
and somehow we have to get we have to
have a way of
saying this they're like no no i have
consciousness at level 20.
or someone who we predict at level 10
said no no i'm i'm actually
consciousness level 5.
well how how does this
it just sounds like a definition yes
there's probably something fishy about
your definition is what i would say
look of course you want you want a
definition that actually agrees
you know to quite some extent with um
what we normally mean by consciousness
right i mean we have we have an idea of
consciousness like
you're conscious i i am conscious uh you
know other people are conscious
um my computer is not conscious at least
not on a noticeable level
you know you could say that maybe the
the task manager or something is
some level of self-awareness but it's so
tiny that
um you know i i can't have a meaningful
conversation with my computer let me put
it like this
and so um if we managed to come up with
some definition of consciousness we will
wanted
to agree with our
our intuition basically for our audience
do you mind explaining i know that
wolfram's theory is not
it's not something you've studied
immensely but wolfram does say that the
universe is inherently computational
what does that mean well
i think you should ask a word from about
this not me okay
okay so your you would say that the mind
body
you know in philosophy there's something
called the mind body problem the mind
body problem itself it's just
body and then no i i don't know i didn't
i said it's solvable it's there seem to
be a lot of people who have this kind of
this
mystic attitude like there's there's
something
so special about consciousness we'll
never be able to
figure out how it works with science and
i'm like
you know let's talk about this again in
100 years and i'll tell you we'll have
figured it out
i see i see okay let's get to your music
what does
what does music do for you are you do
you have this creative
urge this itch inside you that you have
to just get it out there
or or you just do it for fun or or what
there's not many physicists that i know
that post music videos
both i would say um you know i i
definitely have some
need for creative outlet for a long time
i used to paint actually i used to paint
and then
um you know i had kids and uh you know
oil colors and small children don't mix
well
uh so i had to find something else and
that's when i started
writing songs and you know the the i
i'll admit like the first five years
probably the output was pretty terrible
but you know i've learned something sin
since and i really enjoy it you know i i
sometimes feel like if i'm
thinking too much about physics i get a
headache like literally
i i find it really stressful and the
good thing about
um creative enterprise is that it clears
out your mind
you know you get something else in there
and um so i do music
i've uh tried to teach myself how to
sing something that youtube is really
good for by the way
you know right did you also learning
something new did you teach yourself how
to edit or does someone else edit those
music videos
do you use after effects or what oh the
so
so i use premiere pro
and yeah it's pretty much learning by
doing
i guess i've just made every possible
mistake that you can make
and at some point it starts looking kind
of okayish
you know in the sense that if you watch
it on your phone
um you won't be able to see most of the
glitches
so that's kind of i mean i sometimes i
watch
like professionally made videos and i'm
always odd i'm like this is so great you
know
um but uh you know i do what i can do
you know with my little camera with the
autofocus and sometimes it goes wrong
and focuses on the
on the wrong thing or you know stuff
like i forget to plug in the
the microphone cable or stupid things
and then i talk for like an hour and in
the end
i haven't recorded stupid and it can get
really frustrating but
um yeah um you know after after doing
this for a while
you you kind of develop a work routine
and
so so i really do it all myself also the
music videos i mean every once in a
while you know i need someone to hold
the camera
my husband or my brother or my mother
usually um
but other than that i i do it all myself
you know i i write the songs i record
them
i do the mixing um i i do the videos i
do the makeup
the clothing the editing
um everything pretty much yeah do you
find that
your days are are structured where
at the institute you don't have to teach
as far as i know so you pretty much do
research do you
do you wake up at a specific time and
then you
go to bed at a specific time and you
read papers from a certain time
or is it is every day chaotic no
i i'm very much a routine person you
know am i my days
look kind of really yeah yeah but it's
also it's not just me it's because you
know i have two children
uh who normally would go to school so
right now of course the schools are
close but
you know you just you get this routine
because you have to
wake them up and get them to school and
then they come back at a certain time
and
by then you have better done your your
job right
what does your day look like then in
terms of how much time you spend working
and what do you
specifically work on are you reading
papers most of the time are you sitting
with a pen
looking at the wall like i'm i'm
actually interested in the specifics
well so i should probably say that right
now everything is just
different you know normally i would be
at
at my institute but now of course i've
been working for
from home for three months with the kids
in the background
and a lot of stuff didn't really get
done because
you know they're just other things that
keep getting in the way i have to remind
them to do their homework i have to cook
for them that that kind of stuff
so it's not it's not normal the way that
it is right now but
um normally um i mean
so there are there are many different
aspects of um
being a theoretical physicist as you
already pointed out so i work at the
research
institute i don't have teaching duties
and that of course is also part of the
reason why
i'm active in public outreach is kind of
filling in this educational part that
i don't have in my job so i kind of feel
like
i need to give back something to society
because i know some professors they love
research and they
dislike teaching now some are the
opposite i think feynman actually
left the institute because he's like i
gotta teach i can't i have to be in the
field
but many professors that i know they
don't particularly like teaching
it seems like you have
a need to teach a need to give back is
that
you feel like that's missing and so
that's why the youtube videos come about
well um
well it's kind of it's it's a very
different audience you know the
youtube videos are not talking to
students
they're not meant to prepare people for
work in a professional discipline
they're more to generally communicate
what are we actually doing
and personally i find this more relevant
um i guess mostly it's because there are
a lot of people who teach
but i think there are too few people who
do science communication
and so so this is why it's i it's
important to me and
i like doing it even though i'm
technically not getting paid for it
um and um so i would not
describe my outreach activities as
actually being part of my job you know
it's it's something that i
i do on the side for what my research is
concerned
um you know it's indeed mostly reading
you know it's a lot of it the biggest
part is
finding out and understanding what other
people have done including you know the
stuff you
go go to seminars you give seminars
yourself and and
uh that whole game and then of course
you get to a point where you feel like
you've read everything that was to read
on a particular topic
now can i add my own thing um
and that's where you have to sit down
and actually write down equations
uh and see if there's a problem you can
solve or
if there's a new twist you can turn on
um
something and um so
stuff like this then of course i also
have a postdoc and i
have a student um who have their own
projects that i have to look at
and see that they they get to where i
think they should be
getting um and you know there are other
things like i
um organize workshops conferences i have
to review papers
i have to review grant proposals um i
have to write grant proposals this
actually sucks up a dramatic amount of
time
um there's some administrational stuff
that i have to do like if you're getting
grants there's always some overhead that
comes with it that you have to
you know you have to keep track of where
the money goes and fill in reports and
it sounds like that's that's there's so
much extra
on top of the actual research that how
much of your time do you get to spend on
research with you like you said sitting
at your desk with your paper thinking
how can you twist
how can you add your own how can you
contribute to a field
how much of your time do you get to
spend doing that
let's say let's say per day an hour or
two hours
a half hour every week
you know i i would have to think about
this more deeply so
the problem is that um the way that i
work
i kind of i work in phases like i'll
have a phase where i pretty much only do
research like i've been doing now i've
been working on the super determinism
stuff like every day
for 10 hours basically i wake up it's on
my mind you know there's this stuff and
then maybe i can do it this way and you
you know you know down an equation then
you figure out okay i don't know this i
have to look this
up you know then you try this and it
doesn't work and you try to something
else and it goes like this the whole day
until i go to bed
then i wake up in the middle of the
night with an idea and
i'm like oh i have to write this down
okay so then i sleep some more hours and
then i wake up again and i'm like now i
have to look this up
and it may go like this for several
weeks or maybe one two months
and then at some point i'm like i'm like
either totally frustrated and stressed
out and everything and just
have to stop it or something else comes
up
um that just has to be done um you know
conference organization what have you
the proposal deadline
is approaching uh and then something
else takes over
so then for someone i'll be doing
something else and then
i'll be getting back to research so it
makes it very difficult for me to answer
the question in terms of hours per day
um you know i it i guess it's something
between
30 and 50 roughly speaking
that i get to actually work on that's
pretty much yeah i know that
i i'm in a very lucky position
um i know that a lot of
my colleagues especially those who work
in teaching you know have have a lot
more duties um that take time away
from from their research um you know
on the downside though i have to say i
don't have a permanent position you know
i sit on
i sit on temporary contract that will
run out in two years
i was talking to stephen pinker and i
was asking him well how much of your
time is spent
actually writing versus researching and
i think he said it's 90
research that is in your case it would
be the equivalent of reading papers
and then 10 writing for you
how much of how what does that split
look like
well between the between the reading and
the writing there's the calculation part
right so um
for me the writing is kind of the the
least amount of effort
you know it's what i do at the very end
if i have everything together
i sit down right that's what i mean
sorry i'm i'm also including the
calculation in the writing
so the reading and then calculating and
slash writing so it depends on whether
it's a field that i'm already familiar
with
um like if if it's a field like for
example the superfluid dark matter stuff
okay i've been
following the literature on that for
five years
so now the thing is if something new
comes out i only have to read the new
part
so which reduces the amount of
literature that i have to digest
so in any case like this you know it may
be something like
50 50. but if it's if it's a topic that
i'm really new to
um as it was the case up until recently
with the foundations of quantum
mechanics and there's just such a huge
amount
of literature that you first have to get
in and digest that it shifts more to
like
it's 95 uh reading and then there's this
little bit of extra
that you may be able to add i remember
one of your videos and i'm paraphrasing
so please let me know if i'm
mischaracterizing you i don't mean to
you said something along the lines of
that's not you're referring to something
i wish i could remember but he said
that's not a
that's not something i'm interested in
that's not a question that can be
answered with science so i'm not
interested
now you can tell me if i'm wrong there
but i'm curious is all that matters
what can be answered with science
um so i have no idea what i may have
been referring that
it sounds like something that that that
i may have said
in the context of the video probably
you know i was trying to discuss a
scientific question
and then i may have said something uh to
the extent
um but i don't want to talk about this
because it's not a question that science
can answer
um so but this doesn't mean that science
is the only thing that's interesting
like we were already
talking about creative outlets right and
um i i don't think that this is merely
you know something that's unimportant
you know i don't
see myself as a professional artist and
i you know i have no aspirations to
become one to me it's kind of something
that i
need to function properly as a human
basically
but uh i mean there are professional
artists and i think that they
fulfill a very important function in our
society
you know by um giving pleasure to
people's life you know that's something
that
that um is really important so so
science is is definitely not the only
thing that matters
or maybe i should add you know but also
but to make people
think you know art is not only about
what is pretty of course
are there truths that are non-scientific
um yes they're mathematical truths okay
are the truths that are non-mathematical
and non-scientific
well it depends on what you mean by
truth i would say no
because for me a truth is an absolute
truth
you know something that is unshakable
and
you basically only find this in
mathematics if you can actually prove
something like two plus two
equals four so already when you come to
science
um the best you can do is say that
something is
almost certainly correct you know with
with a certain arrow bar
at uh to be almost certainly but
colloquially i guess most people would
at some point
just say it's true you know if the
uncertainty is so small that
uh nothing's going to change about it
almost certainly in their lifetime or
something they would just say it's true
are there truths in fiction
so for example if you watch a movie that
was made up by someone
and you say there's there's truth in
that i mean
i don't know would is there truth in
fiction
well again i i think that's something
which people would say
colloquially but they wouldn't literally
mean
it's true they they would say it um
maybe to mean um
[Music]
this captures something that i have also
experienced or something like that
what's the difference in your eyes
between physics and metaphysics
and just delineate it for the audience
well
i think my if my greek doesn't fail me i
think
the word matter just means beyond so the
the metaphysics or after or something
like this
like it's what what comes after the
physics if you're done with the physics
then there's metaphysics
um but the way that uh it's it's been
mostly used by philosophers
um is to say that in physics you have
certain assumptions that are not
themselves
empirically um testable
but that physicists use nevertheless
um just because they have to
um otherwise nothing works you have to
start with
uh something um and i i guess i'm
i'm i'm hoping that i'm using the word
uh in the same way um that the
philosophers
do like i mean for example
a metaphysical assumption is the idea
that
um
[Music]
theories have to um
fulfill a certain type of beauty that's
what my book is about
um right there's certain types of beauty
that physicists have
been using extensively and
you know i i say that these are ideals
of beauty but what they actually are
are metaphysical criteria it's just that
you know if it's it's not particularly
catchy to talk about
metaphysical criteria so so that's not
what i call it i just say their
appeals to beauty i have a somewhat
technical question
weinstein eric weinstein was talking
about the einstein field equations
dirac equations and then the yang mills
equations and he said
that they are provably the simplest in
their class and
as far as i know there's no theorem in
the field of physics that says that
they're probably the simplest
is there and like what the heck what
does that mean that they're
provably of their kind do you
know well so it's hard to say what what
he
may have been referring to the i mean if
you
because it depends on exactly which
assumptions
uh you make like let let's take for
example general relativity
you can just um general relativity
is a simple theory in the sense that um
it takes only like five assumptions
um to derive it uh
and these five assumptions are kind of
like uh gravity is described by the
curvature of space and time
it couples to the stress energy tensor
which is the conserved quantity uh it
reproduces neutron and gravity
uh in a suitable limit and uh
i think that two more which i've which
i've now forgotten and
then you can show that uh general
relativity
is the simple theory that does that
where the word simple becomes relevant
because
you can you can make the theory more
complicated if you want to
um by adding higher order terms
but but then you just say no i take the
simplest one
i see and uh and i guess that um
it with young myths theory the drock
equation it may be something
similar but again it depends on exactly
how you phrase the assumptions like if
for example with the dirac equation
um dirac made this
assumption that the theory has to be
linear um
which um is something that you may
wonder if you can do it without
so the direct equation is basically
you're trying to take the square root
of um einstein's equation e
e squared minus p squared equals m
squared
and so the peculiar thing about the
derog equation is that you take the
square root but you get a linear
equation
and the only way you can do that is by
using these weird matrices
but in principle you can take a square
root of an operator
that's something which exists and you
you can define that uh by
using the spectral uh decomposition and
i've no idea why
why dirk didn't try that or maybe he did
and you know
he didn't like it or whatever people
tried it later
their papers about this um and
you know then you you can i don't know
how
is one of these solutions simpler than
the other i don't know but one is wrong
and the other one isn't
like i mean wrong in the sense that
derek's equation actually describes
reality well if you do it the other way
around
you also get a theory that kind of
solves the problem that derock posed
like how do i take the square root of
that right
doesn't describe what we observe so i
see this
question doesn't make much sense but
it's fun to think about
imagine you're a photon how do you
experience time
now i know time is defined as the length
the path length
in space time but proper time is so
that means that the photon experiences
zero time which is
imagining you're the photon it's it's
like you you're emerging and then you
die instantaneously
what does the experience of a photon
look like
i have no idea i don't know what it
means to talk about the
experience of a photon like we were
talking about um
consciousness earlier and i think that
you can
define experience in a similar way but
it requires that you have a certain
amount of particles that are able to
actually exchange information
and so i would say a single photon just
doesn't have any experiences i have no
idea what that's
supposed to mean so uh yeah i'm not sure
that
answers your question but yeah i mean
the canonical answer to the question is
that uh
photons um don't can't have a sense of
time
basically exactly because of this issue
that
that you're pointing out so the the
length of the curve
on which the photon moves is zero and uh
the length of this curve is usually what
you mean by time
sabine what's next for you and
why don't you tell our audience where
they can find out more about you
your youtube link will be included well
so um i'm lucky in that
for all i know i'm the only person on
this planet with the names of being a
hostenfelder so the only thing you have
to do is
enter my name in some search engine and
you will find out more about me than you
ever wanted to know
trust me um so that's the easy part um
the complicated part is uh what i'm
going to do
so um like the next two years are
pretty straightforward because i'm
working on this research project
on superfluid dark matter so that's what
i'll be doing
i also have this running research
project on super determinism
um that we talked about um and i'm also
you know i i was in the process of
organizing a workshop on that
um which was supposed to take place in
may but then we had to cancel everything
i'm glad because when i wrote that
question i wasn't sure if you were
familiar with the term super determinism
and it turns out you're a specialist in
the field
yeah you know it was lucky because as i
keep joking the only
three people on the planet who
understand what super determinism is so
that's
uh that's me and jarrah toofed and tim
palmer
so you're talking to exactly the right
person
um yes uh and i'll
i'll keep on doing the youtube thing for
some more time definitely
i'm kind of getting into it you know the
the more practice you have the easier it
gets because you become more efficient
um with producing content if you don't
make
as many mistakes um
but beyond this i really don't know
because i'm i'm sitting on this
short-term contract and there's always
the question like uh
will i get another research grant or if
not then
what am i supposed to do so your future
in the next five years if this was a job
interview what does your future look
like
you're not clear in the next five years
you hopefully yeah i failed
i failed the interview so what if
someone gave you
a million dollars and said i want you to
spend this and just make music videos or
just
pursue music would you say yes or no is
it that much of a passion
compared to physics
well you know i i wouldn't want to give
up my research
um on the other hand i could put it on
pause
for some time uh so i guess it depends
on how many
of the right incentives yeah it it's
it's a matter of time period that
um he or she would expect me to spend
away from research
it's not really amount about the amount
of money oh okay okay
all right thank you so much sabine
appreciate this
and have a great day everyone go visit
her channel
check it out subscribe
are you aware of any other logical
approaches to
of any other logics that are used in
the building of physical theory so for
example
most of physical theories are grounded
in classical logic that is p or not p
and you can't have both why else do you
have principle of explosion well that is
the principle
okay well
there is consistent logics and
intuitionist logics
there is something called quantum logic
so people have tried to
um i i never followed this in much
detail but i heard like one two talks
about it yeah as you say that they're
different
systems of logic and people have tried
to
use them to um
explain the puzzling aspects of quantum
theory as just being a different type of
logic
um where statements don't have to be
mutually exclusive
so no so um which is supposedly where
you get
um all this stuff from that uh you know
estate can be both here and there
because these options are not exclusive
so that's kind of
the vague idea um but
you know i don't know i i heard about
this first i think 10 years ago and not
all that much seems to have come out of
it but yeah i mean this would be the
first thing that comes to my mind
i'm curious if there are from the
popularizers of science much like
neil degrasse tyson and so on if there
are myths that you feel like
that they sell to the audience that that
is incorrect that you wish they wouldn't
so for example that the electron is both
up and down at the same time rather than
that being just
a method that we use mathematically to
calculate what
happened that's just part of the wave
function it's not necessarily that the
electron is both up and down do you
happen to know of any other
misconceptions that you want to dispel
so i i don't know i don't know about
uh tyson or yeah it doesn't sound
particular yeah
there are a few of these that sometimes
come up that
the problem is that i have a hard time
pulling them up now because i didn't
think about it
previously but one thing that would come
to my mind uh
immediately is this idea that the
observations on the bullet cluster
rule out modified gravity which is
which is wrong and i think everyone who
works in the field knows that it's wrong
but it's such a
simple and seemingly uh intuitive
explanation that
that science communicators draw on it um
all the time
and i find it really really misleading
and i think it's really bad for the
field because
a lot of people in physics who are not
really familiar with the with the
subject matter just believe it
and um yes so this is one example
another example
is that um i i often hear people say
that
um special relativity um
cannot deal with accelerated observers
which is which is wrong you can
perfectly
well deal with accelerated observers in
special relativity it's just that
a lot of you know popular science
textbooks only talk about
um non-accelerated observers the reason
this
annoys me is that if you believe that
you can't understand the equivalence
principle because the equivalence
principle says that
acceleration in flat space in
special relativity is locally equivalent
uh to um gravity uh in a curved space so
if you
if you can't deal with acceleration and
special relativity makes no sense
whatsoever
so the whole point about general
relativity is that it uses
special relativity and generalizes it so
so that's another one of these things
another thing that
more recently upsets me is that you have
probably heard
that um there is a type of dark matter
that is
um increasing in popularity right now
which is called the axion
and the story that they always tell if
you read these
popular science articles is that the
axion was
proposed in the 1970s by frank wilczyk
and stephen weinberg independently
as a solution to a particular problem in
the standard model which is called the
strong cp problem
and that's true in that um
they proposed this particle in the 1970s
but what they don't tell you
is that this particle was ruled out two
years after it was proposed it's just
not compatible with observations
and the thing that they search for now
is
a strongly modified version of this
original idea which is called the
invisible axiom
and so the reason this annoys me that
they leave this out
is that this is symptomatic to what is
going on in the foundations of physics
more generally that
after a model has been ruled out
physicists don't give up on it and say
okay
this didn't work instead they will
fiddle with the model
uh until it's compatible with data again
then it will do another experiment and
it would rule it out again and then they
put it with the model again and and
that's been going on for 40 years
so i feel that by leaving out this part
of the history
people get a very wrong impression of
what people are actually looking for
today
you